digamos que queremos encontrar 6 entre
0.2 y 2 decimos entonces pausa el vídeo
y ver si puedes encontrarlo bien ya
hemos explorado varias estrategias una
de ellas es expresar esto como una
fracción es decir escribir esto como 6
sobre 0.2 y tal vez podríamos
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por algún valor y así ya no
estaríamos tratando con el problema de
los decimales qué te parece si
multiplicamos estos dos décimos por 10
para quitar los decimales pero si
multiplicamos lo de abajo por 10
entonces necesitamos también multiplicar
el numerador por 10 para no afectar la
operación que se observa es simplemente
multiplicar por 1 así que no estamos
cambiando su valor entonces esto va a
ser igual a 60 60 entre y me quedan 2
decimos por 10 y observa podemos mover
el punto decimal 1 a la derecha y
entonces esto de aquí me quedaría igual
a 2 ahora cuanto 60 entre dos buenos 60
entre 2 es bastante sencillo 6 entre dos
es 3
entonces 60 entre 2 va a ser igual a 30
entonces esto es 30 y hemos terminado
ahora otra estrategia que pudieron haber
pensado y tal vez utilizado es escribir
todos estos números en términos de
décimos pudieran haber dicho observa
este es 60 decimos y los tengo divididos
entre dos decimos dos décimos es lo
mismo que 0.2 y esto es igual a bing si
tengo sesenta grupos de algo y si tengo
que dividirlo en dos grupos de ese algo
entonces tendrían 30
esto sería igual a 30 muy bien de lujo
vamos a hacer otro más
ahora vamos a calcular cuánto es 4.2 o 4
y dos décimos ok
entre 0.3 pasos el vídeo y ves puedes
encontrar la respuesta bien ya hemos
visto varias técnicas para abordar esto
y hemos visto que nunca puede escribir
esto como una fracción entonces vamos a
escribir lo pueden escribir esto como
4.2 sobre 0.3 y ahora vamos a poder
tratar de deshacernos de los decimales y
la mejor manera de hacer esto es bueno
aquí tengo todo en decimos así que si
multiplicó el numerador y el denominador
por 10 esto nos va a facilitar mucho
esta operación así que en el numerador
el decimal se movería uno a la derecha
entonces el numerador quedaría como 42
4.2 por 10 642 sobre 0.3 por 10 bien eso
va a ser igual a 3 y entonces cuánto es
42 entre 3 bueno hay varias maneras de
hacer esto pueden tratar de hacerlo
solamente o sólo intentar hacer una
división a medio larga esa división no
debería de ser tan larga es esta
aquí
42 entre 3 y bueno 3 entran en 4 una vez
1 por 3 estrés y restan 4 menos 3 lo
cual es una baja en el 2 y me queda 12
entre 3 lo cual es 4 veces
entonces me queda de resultado 14 4.2
entre 0.3 es 14 y como lo vimos en el
último ejemplo también podemos plantear
esto si lo escribimos en decimos porque
4.2 es lo mismo que 42 decimos esto
dividido entre 3 decimos en donde 42 de
algo dividido en tres grupos de ese algo
bueno vamos a terminar otra vez con 14
así que espero que aprecien todas estas
ideas y puedan expresar esto como una
fracción vean se pueden multiplicar el
numerador y el denominador por el mismo
valor y tal vez eliminen todos los
decimales
otra forma es plantear estos números en
términos de decimos o centésimos y luego
plantear 2 de esta manera como vimos
y cualquiera de estas combinaciones van
a ser estrategias efectivas o con suerte
estrategias efectivas para dividir
decimales o dividir números donde el
cociente podría ser un decimal en los
siguientes vídeos vamos a aprender una
manera estándar más sistema temática de
poder hacerlo pero que siempre es útil
si alguien se dirige a mí en la calle me
pregunta cuántos 4.200 0.3 bueno de esta
forma es como en realidad yo lo haría
dirían muy bien esto es lo mismo que 42
entre 3 y bueno observaría que 3 entre
el 42 veamos tres por diez es 30 y luego
3 por 4 12 entonces serían 14 veces y
justo así es como mi cerebro lo haría